comme si l'arménie n'était pas le même
sujet que celui qui nous occupe et nous
préoccupe
voir nous obsède aujourd'hui c'est à
dire le combat contre l'islamiste dont
note remise intérieure dont le président
a public dont le premier se déclare
qu'il est primordial
j'ai passé plusieurs jours en arménie et
dans la région qu'on appelle l'art ksar
pour les arméniens le haut karabagh pour
les a's eric est une région qui donc au
sud du caucase entre l'iran la turquie
la géorgie et la mer caspienne
parce que l'urss a explosé bien cette
région demander son rattachement à
l'arménie les aziri n'ont pas voulu une
guerre était enclenché les arméniens ont
gagné et cet automne armées azéries
soutenu voie recommandée par des turcs
par l'armée turque e deuxième armée de
l'otan et des mercenaires djihadistes
venant de syrie via la turquie
d'ailleurs viala par la volonté l'air
dogan qui ont décidé d'attaquer de
récupérer cette région sont du côté
arménien des tranchées on est on est
dans les tranchées de 14-18 est vraiment
une nation en armes et les gens ne sont
pas du tout militariste pas du tout
nationaliste pas du tout guerrier 10
juste si on ne se bat pas nous seront
exterminées qu'ils aient raison ou non
en tout cas c'est leur raisonnement est
donc ça leur paraît naturel de prendre
leurs armes
on a vu dans les hôpitaux des blessés
avec des blessures très impressionnante
notamment des gens brûlés au phosphore
de faux soit réutilisé interdit bien
entendu utilisés par l'armée azérie pour
nettoyer les forêts parce que c'est
compliqué traverser une forêt pour
parler d'un point à un autre surtout en
montagne
donc c'est plus pratique de bombarder au
phosphore sauf que parfois il y avait
des civils ce qui était frappant dans ce
dans ce conflit c'est le silence et
l'absence de la diplomatie européenne et
française en particulier les arméniens
sur place misait bas votre président au
moins il a désigné l'agresseur alief
l'azerbaïdjan il a dit qu'il y avait des
mercenaires djihadistes via la turquie
qui était venu donc ça macron l'a dit
sauf que votre ministre des affaires
étrangères monsieur le drian lui a dit
oulala
la france est neutre dans ce conflit
fourneaux c'est trop conflit c'est
l'orient compliqué il ya un agressé en
agressé mais laissées par ati
deux arméniens ont décliné dépendance
d'un état qui n'a pas lieu d'être
donc c'est pas notre problème on n'a pas
à prendre partie d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
on va livrer de l'aide humanitaire et
aux uns et aux autres c'est pour moi on
te d'estimer qu on accorde une aide
humanitaire d'un côté un pays qui
utilisent des mercenaires jihadistes à
ma connaissance sont nos ennemis y
compris en france et de l'autre côté
notamment des civils des femmes des
enfants
vous avez vu des groupes parlementaires
s'offusquer est-ce que vous avez une
résolution à l'assemblée nationale au
sénat
condamnant l'agression azéri condamnant
l'utilisation de mercenaires djihadistes
venant de syrie qu on a combattu que des
soldats français ont combattu et
combattent aujourd'hui au mali dont nous
subissons les assauts avec le terrorisme
en france rien du tout comme si
l'arménie n'était pas le même sujet que
celui qui nous occupe et nous préoccupe
voir nous obsède aujourd'hui c'est à
dire le combat contre l'islamisme
vous avez un espace pour erdogan
c'est vraiment le sultan dans sa dans
toute sa splendeur il a complètement
reconstitué un empire ottoman 2.0 qui
part de istanbul et qui va jusqu'à
bichkek au kirghizistan
c'est à dire des dizaines de faim des
milliers de kilomètres de largeur sans
interruption la seule interruption qui
existait sur cette carte
jusqu'à maintenant c'était l'arménie ce
petit état chrétien depuis le quatrième
siècle premier état chrétien au monde
est sacrifié sur l'autel des accords
économiques financiers géopolitique voir
moreau du monde entier
[Musique]